thank you everybody for joining my name
is mark tyrell it's the 3 30 session on
the last day of pi data global
i have uh with me here
timi lalua and thank you for the
pronunciation
display in your name it's very helpful
because otherwise i might be a bit lost
there
so
tamilalua will be
talking to us today about
data quality
so why don't you go ahead and you can
introduce yourself because i'm sure
you'll do a better job than i would
thank you for the introduction thank you
for having me let me talk
yeah so i'm going to share my screen
with you guys yeah so today i just like
to talk about uh so much data such poor
quality
i think it's a really important topic to
cover uh because i i feel like as the
world is
developing a
increase increasingly uh keener interest
in ai and big data and how people are
really excited about it i think that we
have uh lost track of making sure that
we have data quality measures in place
to
keep track with this interest
so uh here's over what i'll be talking
about a little about a little bit about
me how data is rapidly changing and
growing at a crazy rate and how um this
is having an impact on data quality and
also some data quality tools you can use
for um yourself or for your institution
so that we can all grow as a community
um in improving data quality
so
here's a little bit about my background
so my data engineer and biomedical
engineer
i have been um doing
uh
the area of this uh work in this area
for about a little bit over 10 years now
i've been i've done a bunch of stuff
i've done like cancer research and
bio um additive research and
uh
lots of cool stuff in academic research
consulting first a lot of big companies
um entrepreneurship including having a
biotech startup focused on diagnosing um
pneumonia and pediatric cases
and it's been a really cool experience
but i think from all all these
experiences it really has made me more
passionate about having quality data so
that you can't have those business
insights that you want and you can have
as those health care insights that you
want
oh and also i'm a project or tech grad i
love dirty tech
data is increasing at a rapid rate so
according to the idc global data sphere
by 2025 is expected that we'll have 175
data bytes of data that's a lot
so if you could
wrap
um
dvds on top of each other around the
world
uh this would be equivalent to wrapping
around the world 221 times
if you are downloading this data at like
an average internet speed it would take
you more than
2.18 billion years to download all this
data it's a lot of data
and like i said earlier people are super
excited about it but what about the
quality of the data that we're making
every day is it really giving us what we
need so that we can have those insights
that we want
but what happens when
this data goes wrong right when you have
poor quality data it impacts businesses
and institutions in rural ways
so according to the mit sloan management
review and 2017 report
they say that um 15 to 25 percent of
revenue can be lost due to poor quality
data
that's a lot right and so we we just
look at the health industry loan in the
us not the whole world just the us we're
talking about an industry that's more
than 10 trillion dollars right
so just in that industry alone we're
talking about more than two trillion
dollars lost every year due to poor
quality data
that's a craft load of money being lost
every year when you think about all the
industries that are put together when
you put together health care and banking
and
business to business um institutions and
education it's a lot of money being lost
every year
around the world
but it's more than money like i think
people think about money because
something that we can measure
and it's something that we can clearly
see
but we're also talking about a bigger
impact of money you're having an
increased risk exposure
um
for various industries
decreased regulatory compliance and also
i would say most importantly maybe even
more important than those two is having
improperly informed decisions with
severe outcomes when we're talking about
some high stake industries
but uh to me um from my perspective some
of the high-stakes industries
where we really had to be vigilant about
data quality
is definitely um healthcare logistics in
the financial sector
and i know i chose these three because
these are the ones that i have
experience with
and i just want to all right let's let
me know if i'm speaking too quickly uh
or anything i guess are you going to
slow down
sounds good for my side
okay
okay
uh something i think that we all have
thought about
over the past almost like what two years
now dealing with cobit 19
uh is
how logistics like was a nightmare right
so i think we think about our personal
experiences of like going to the grocery
store and not being able to get toilet
paper or your favorite snacks and you
know how inconvenient that was and i
think for uh
fortunately uh for most people probably
uh who got a chance to come to the
conference it was probably just an
inconvenience right
but there were people who were severely
impacted by
data quality issues to me on copic 19
and like food waste and food insecurity
um
then this shouldn't have happened
right so one of the biggest challenges
of logistics um that hackman cope at 19
was food waste and security
so in one part of our ecosystem with our
food ecosystem supply chain
we had people who were literally food
insecure people who had lost their jobs
people had been laid off we were now
having to go to soup kitchens and
and seeking out help from places that
people who had never done this before
these are people who were you know
previous to cope 19 or economically
stable families right
but then on the other end of the supply
chain we literally had farmers have who
are being forced to dump milk and to
plow over produce because there was a
bottleneck of oversupply now you think
to yourself how is that possible to have
an oversupply at one end
and then literally people being food
insecure and families going hungry
somebody at the other end
it's a logistics problem and a poor poor
data quality issue to me in addition to
some other just you know business
problems right so these farmers were
being forced to
dump millions of gallons of milk you
know every um every day
because they didn't have anywhere to
send it these farmers were used to
dealing with you know large customers
like restaurants and schools are now
closed because of covet 19
and because you know milk is a
perishable vinyl on perishable item
eggs produce you can't keep that for
long term
but there's no way in the system
just to work to me timeliness of the
data was really key in this and being
able to connect the two
the two areas right the area of need in
the area of like oversupply
when you don't have a time like the
timely date and you don't have accurate
data you don't have um
a robust logistics system with that
quality data in place you have issues
like this that happen and
these things already existed right and
they still exist covet 19 is exposed
these issues in a way that we probably
had never you know seen before
and again there are obviously some
business issues there and how do you
retool something that you know machines
that were
you know supposed to be making products
for you know large-scale consumers to
individual consumers
obviously that that will have to be
addressed too but also just a lack of
data
but how do you because you don't if you
don't have a timely data you don't have
the accurate data to connect these um
two parties
then you have um the the big impact of
like the food insecurity at the same
time of having overproduction by these
farmers
it blows my mind and i think um at the
center of that it's definitely a data
quality problem
but this is just one example to me of
data quality issues um
that are
just to get used more attention in the
world right now
finance is a big data quality issue
um problem
that we have to continue to be vigilant
about because of the big impact of it
so
just like our one great example is that
in october 2020 it was like just like a
little bit less than a little bit more
than a year ago
citibank was fined more than 400 million
dollars by u.s regulators because of
several long-sitting deficiencies in his
data governance and data um risk
management practices what does that mean
in everyday terms this means they have
like poor quality checkpoints in place
to make sure that the data is supposed
to be they didn't have uh testing
protocols in place
they were consistent to be able to
verify and validate that uh funds were
in certain places
when they really weren't um or somewhere
else
in one instance of
the reasons why the regulators cited and
fined city banks because they had sent
more than 900 million dollars to the
wrong
customer one of their creditors
and then uh this was just one example
but they had actually sent large sums of
money to wrong customers and some of the
customers um didn't agree to send the
money back but
but then what do you do when this bank
is fdic insured it's supposed to be
compliant with all the regulations in
place but they're not
the robust security protocols in place
that the money is going to the correct
customers that your um
the money is being um checked that you
have the verification and validation
produced procedures in place uh to make
sure that this this data about your your
customers is secure not just like large
corporations and large creditors but
also everyday customers
if their data is not secure when you go
to go to the local bank
to get a loan for your first home
and they deny you based off of poor data
who's there to to check them
you know i think that they were properly
cited uh for
um
consistently having issues over years
this is one issue that they have been
fined for but this is just one bank
so think about the the high risk
uh and rewards that happen when you have
either good financial data or poor
financial data how it impacts everyday
people and how it impacts
big industry and how it impacts the
stock market overall in our economy it's
like too important for us to not have
quality data and quality verification
validation procedures in place
to make sure the data is what it's
supposed to be
but to me like okay we've we've talked
about food insecurity we've talked about
logistics and we've talked about
finances
but above all and because like health
care is in my heart i would say that
health care
is the biggest um opportunity for us to
be vigilant about data quality because
we're literally talking about
life-and-death situations
ecri in one survey
of about almost like 200 hospitals asked
me there were 7 600 wrong patient events
over a 32 month period
this led to
in nine percent of these cases
patients either being harmed or even
death
that's ridiculous right
so a lot of the issues that ecr ecri
found were like mismatched records
um patients who had similar names are
being confused
um
gaps in the patient data
and you think okay this is this is
probably not very common this is
actually very common you think about um
like how patients will go from maybe one
doctor to another like someone moves
from one city to another and how gaps in
the patient's records exist or how
there's poor integration between
hospitals even the same city
like they don't have any contingency
plans for inheriting that data together
and validating it
or if you know someone has a common
lasting like johnson or smith
you know maybe having extra verification
and validation procedures in place to
make sure that this patient is
who is sitting in front of this
this doctor
like it's
it's crazy but it has life and in-depth
outcomes we're talking about
diagnosis
um also
the huge cost to insurance
uh there was another study that said
that more than a third of insurance
claims that were denied were because of
mismatch patient records
that's how common it is right
and so this is happening more a lot more
common than people um think it is
and we're talking about uh the
difference between someone getting
life-saving treatment potentially and
not getting that
so this is happening in just a small
sample of hospital suited hospitals
think about how calmness is across
hospitals all across the us and in the
world
and i'll say another reason why this
happens very often is because of legacy
systems right
so hospitals usually do not um their
technology does not change the same pace
as other business
sectors because of the it's a higher
regulatory environment
and then when you're talking about
combining maybe even paper records with
electronic records and they're not being
a system in place again verification
validation procedures
that makes it really challenging for
clinicians because clinicians really
shouldn't be responsible for this i
think that there needs to be
a better partnership with technologists
with
you know people who
work in quality control the data
analysts data scientists data engineers
um so that we can fix this issue because
it's a it's bad for the clinicians who
want to give their patients great care
and it's bad for patients who want to
receive great care and want to leave the
hospital with less issues than when they
went to the hospital
so it's a big problem i definitely would
say um
this this challenge has happened with
ecri and their survey happening because
of poor checkpoints again for validating
data in the integration of systems
and i think that uh through these these
three examples of
data quality challenges it's important
to talk about you know what things
should you be looking out for when
you're trying to improve your data
quality and you're trying to manage it
these are some of the core elements to
me that are important to having big data
quality that would be completeness
making sure that your records are
complete from like when they when they
should start when they should end
traceability of the records are you able
to see
as the data is navigating for your
ecosystem
the lineage of that data
who initiated or you know created the
data who who are the
internal customers for that data who are
the external customers that data
how often is it is that data being used
is it being changed how are you tracking
that in your system in your overall data
governance plan
what are your validation and
verification um plans
for this data how are you able to look
for anomalies and drift and for error
and then what is your acceptable range
of error like there are a lot of
companies that don't have
verification and validation plans in
place
and don't have a predetermined um error
point because you need to be able to
have that pretty
determined point of acceptable error
place
so that you can say okay hey if this
goes beyond this you know five percent
error that we think is um
agreeable for for this particular data
point but we know we need to raise the
red flag we need to send the alarms off
and say hey we need to go look and see
why this error is happening data and see
if we can fix it at the source level
and also um how many unique data records
are there um are you able to distinguish
between you know one record and the next
and then also is it consistent and
timeliness i'll say timeliness is one of
the biggest challenges for most
companies right so for most data
scientists and data analysts they spend
majority of their time wrangling the
data and make trying to get into the
proper form so they can actually be
usable for the company
and that to me is very inefficient it's
a poor use of human capital
um or you know your staff that you have
available and it's something that could
definitely be reduced it's not going to
be medicated completely
but if you can make sure there's a
baseline quality of data at the
ingestion points and checkpoints about
your system you can save so much
efficiency for your companies
and then also i just wanted some video
quality tools i talked about
i may have to switch the screens i think
i just you know pressed me adobe but um
to show you the links
uh there's azure purview
azure preview is a pretty new a new tool
to microsoft it's about less than two
years old so still kind of nascent but
it does have some good features into
manage data quality
um looking at the lineage of the data
um having different drivers available to
connect to you know azure like the azure
ecosystem for microsoft within um their
having a data dictionary and be able to
see what terms are uh in the data and
being able to track the data
but it's still pretty new
and then you also have calibra
calibra is a great tool clebra is uh i
should say azure is through
subscriptions you have to pay for that
libra is a great tool is also for pay
through subscription usually you're
going to see like large educational
institutions
or um
you know just like large companies use
it because it's kind of costly and it's
going to depend on like the cost the
cost of depending on the features that
you want on this system but it has a
great um data quality feature including
um ldq
ldq was acquired by felibra in the past
several years it has like some machine
learning features look for drift anomaly
detached in the data it has a data
catalog kind of similar to like um your
experience if you were shopping for data
sets like on in like
amazon you're shopping for something you
can have data sets shopping inside of
your organization it's pretty cool when
you have
privacy properties also pretty similar
to libra
it can connect to a lot of external
drivers
then you but to me i think the biggest
opportunities are for open open source
tools right because a lot of times
through the development that happens
through open source tools
it creates better for pay and open
source tools that come from that
apache griffin apache atlas
are two apache tools they're really
great together for your data quality and
for your overall data governance apache
griffin
can ingest the data sets and see changes
in it over time
um
it doesn't have as many features as some
of the for paid tools but it's a great
initial tool to begin your data quality
journey and it's for free
so you can um make adjustments to it or
add additional features that you'd like
and apache atlas is a great tool for
managing your data dictionary
managing your business dictionary
adding some security features to um
to your existing data infrastructure and
adminson is a is also a great tool i
want to see we have a little bit time i
want to go to
um apache atlas and griffin and show you
how it looks i'm going to exit of this
and then i'm going to go to my other
screen
see
so i'm going to go to screen share and
i'll go to
screen 2
and then
should be able to see this and so then
when i click on apache girlfriend it's
like wow
okay
so can you see this apache griffin
yeah we can see it now okay
so you can see it's like getting started
it allows you to define your data
quality metrics um it allows you to have
a scheduler it looks for these
particular measures for data quality the
accuracy completeness timeliness
uniqueness folder be consistent like i
said the core elements of data quality
and this was initially developed as an
open source product from ebay is really
great and there's a nice little like
user interface that allows you to easily
manage it so even if you have like some
non-people in your team
as long as it's like
initial the api is
you know set up with your system by your
engineers not technical people can
easily use it too
i'm going to show you some other ones
too it's apache atlas also is a really
great tool
not just for data quality for data
governance overall
a little bit slow see
somebody's not connecting
it might be their website
it's okay
let me show you the other ones
i don't want to show you a for pay
option too
there are some advantages to going ahead
and paying additional costs for
using
a bigger company
so
to me is one for like as far as the four
paid products go it's one of the best
products in the market for data quality
because they have a complete solution
for data governance
so
um
you can uh
have data quality a data governance um
plan
completely managed in the platform
um usable for business users and for
technical users you did a one inch you
did quality but definitely for like ldq
it's is uh really really like a leader
for
for calibra
let's see
here we
go won't get to the other products i
want to like have a few minutes for
questions but one of the things i really
like about calibra is the machine
learning feature
so for the a lot of the other data
quality tools you have to individually
go in and define what you want those
rules to be like which what's my error
range going to be what's the how do i
define an anomaly within my data set
with um calibra they allow
a wide range of data sources to be
ingested um with their jbdc drivers so
it can be from aws it could be from
azure it could be from
postgres uh my sql database it really
doesn't matter like any database you can
think of is on here it's freaking
amazing
i'm biased because i i've used this tool
um significantly for customers and i
really like it
um but it's great i mean you can look
for undiscovered um rules anomaly
detection data reconciliation
sensitivity um so maybe um if you know
someone in your team didn't initially
recognize the data was sensitive
recognizes it
it means a lot of great options out
there
for pay and for free
and um
i just i i i hope that people become
like more aware of it the importance and
the impact of data quality issues
and um
that there are tools and there's a
community of people who are excited
about this and you want to improve it i
want to give the last minutes for q a if
anybody has any questions i would love
to answer them and thank you for taking
the time to listen to tv
thank you uh timothy lua that was really
uh
exciting i love your enthusiasm uh
especially for the libra um in
particular yeah the finance and health
care examples shocking stuff
uh so the q a is open
please go ahead and ask your questions
there or in the chat
i have a question for you so
you came from like a technical
background but then you got into data
governance
yeah okay so i my little pivot or
whatever happened i would say in grad
school
um so um i went to um grad school tech
and i was in the medical device
development program so that's like
not just like developing like the
devices themselves but learning about uh
risk risk control and risk mitigation
and developing validation verification
testing because that's like a very very
big um
like
focus for the fda
like
the thing they care most about is like
being able to consistently reproduce the
same product like does it do what it's
going to do
all the time
and um that may be interested in public
policy so then i got linked with the
public policy department at georgia tech
and they made me really interested in
quality like how does quality connect to
data how does it connect to healthcare
and i think that it's something that
just is really overlooked because of
like how important quality is for
healthcare i feel like people in
technology don't think about those
verification validation plans and
quality is just like oh it works
you need bugs this time but you need
both and so i like the fact that i'm
like
like at the intersection of both like i
have a chance to make technology but
then also bring that like public policy
healthcare aside into it and say like
hey is this reproducible can we verify
it can we validate it and then what
tools and tests we have in place to make
sure that that's happening
yeah i think that really adds a lot of
value
a question from jorge how much config
does each tool need for example for
sensible information i guess galibra is
tuned for the u.s market
uh not much other countries where things
like social security number doesn't
exist i'm sure it's adaptable now
well it's definitely adaptable um so it
can so it's not like the configurability
that's required it's gonna vary for each
tool i'll definitely say for the open
source tool you're gonna have to do some
more leg work because they are open
source so they're not as user-friendly
don't have like a large staff like
making it as user-friendly
like for um
for griffin if you like let's say that
your company is using um a cloud
computing environment you're gonna have
to set up a virtual machine then you're
gonna have some api and then connect to
your system but once you get through
that stuff it is user friendly after
that
for the other tools that are for pay
they're definitely more user-friendly
because they're more people working on
it so like for prophecy and for calibra
it's made for your business user as well
as for your technical user and so you
can literally um you're going to need
some help taking the the jb dc driver so
those are the drivers that connect to
external source of data
but after that like your regular regular
team members your your secretary your
business manager they can go in and use
um tools like calibra
and prophecy like very easily because
they're made for the like having the
business user and the technical user in
mind and you said you know is it for
just the us or abroad um for most these
systems they can recognize like
different sensitive informations across
countries because i know like in the u.s
like a example of sensitive information
would be like
credit card number
or your social security number whatever
that equivalent is
they can usually recognize that because
they have customers all over the world
all around the world i would say that's
one strength that azure has because
microsoft has so many customers around
the world like almost every freaking
country there is they easily recognize
like national numbers or different
countries like ideas of sensitive
information
um but then you can always like i said
no matter if it's open source or if it's
for paid you can change that and figure
it to you know what your needs are
cool okay great stuff we're actually out
of time uh there's a few more questions
in the chat
please feel free to take those up on
slack uh with timing so thank you again
very much appreciate it